welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
I'm sitting in for David today I'll be
here with the next few days with you as
well something over the weekend
definitely bears talking about a little
bit more than has already been fleshed
out I believe and that is the fact that
the DNC voted this past Saturday to
strip super-delegates of their power
kind of tighten I mean did they really
when you read beyond the headlines that
do tell us how Democrats are taking
super delegate power away they're really
not though and that's what got me really
riled up this past weekend I saw these
headlines I saw the tweets everybody
talking about what a great move this is
and don't get me wrong it is a
phenomenal first step and I do not at
all want to undermine the hard work of
the true progressives in the Democratic
Party on that unity reform commission
who made this happen they worked their
tails off to get this done unfortunately
those in power at the DNC did not take
it as far as was needed right because
here's what happens right now with the
super-delegates under the new rules they
are not allowed to vote in a first-round
ballot that's it that's it that's the
power they were stripped up you just
can't vote in a first-round ballot if it
goes to a second round guess what
super-delegates are right back in there
ready to sway in election one way or the
other so nothing changes and there's
actually still another caveat that if
one nominee has already secured enough
of the vote you know they've already won
enough delegates that they will win no
matter what
then the super-delegates are allowed to
go ahead and vote in that first round
ballot just I guess so they can feel
special and powerful for a few minutes
none of this makes any sense I mean
there is no way to slice the whole super
delegate thing to where it
since these people who come in as
super-delegates the powerful elite you
know whoever they may be they
essentially get to vote twice okay
the other delegates who are there also
voted obviously most likely in the
primaries but they only get to cast the
other ballot based on what their state
voted for so it's not a second vote
they're just there representing to cast
that delegate vote the super-delegates
on the other hand they can go to the
polls on primary day cast their ballot
and there goes one vote towards towards
their candidate then they get to the
convention and they get to cast a
independent vote that is equal to every
other delegate in that room how is that
fair how is that democratic how is that
going with the will of the people and I
know super-delegates most of the time
we'll go with the will of the people but
there is no point to it either you want
to go with the will of the people or you
don't you either go with whoever wins
the popular vote of the primaries and
wins the most delegates state-by-state
or you don't that's the problem here
super-delegates should not have a role
within the Democratic Party or a
Republican Party which they don't but
they shouldn't have a role in politics
they shouldn't exist it shouldn't be a
thing that we have to talk about it
shouldn't be something that the
progressives within the Democratic Party
are having to fight to have removed
there are so many battles that should be
taking place right now both within the
party and outside of it and yet we are
having to have some of our best and
brightest people go to the DNC and try
to convince them to actually strip
super-delegates of their power we still
have a party that refuses to add a ban
on fracking to their platform they voted
that down back in 2016 and yet
here we are rather than talking policy
rather than coming up with a party
platform that works for the party that
has good solid messaging that everybody
wants to hear instead of doing that
we're having fights over super-delegates
still that's not productive and again I
am not in any way trying to undermine
the hard work of people who made this
happen it was a fight that needed to
happen and it had to happen
unfortunately it's not a fight that if
the Democratic Party had done what was
right we would have even had to have had
in the first place we should be talking
policy right now we should be meeting
with the party leaders meeting with the
people running for office in this year's
midterms and coming up with a strategy
but instead we have to go back and
rehash these wounds from 2016 because we
as a party the Democrats just kind of
seem incapable of any kind of solid
reflection on themselves and that can
hurt them now there's progress being
made
obviously stripping super-delegates of
some of their power again great positive
step but it is a baby step okay this is
not a be-all end-all for super delegates
they still have power in any power that
they hold is too much power but but at
least for the time being
they have shown the the party elite the
establishment the leadership have shown
that they're willing to give some
concessions so if they're willing to
give those concessions let's keep going
and they are I mean the people in the
Unity Commission are absolutely pushing
forward they're getting things done this
was just the first battle they had to
wage but they are not done but there's
another flip side of this that I think
needs to be talked about I think right
now the Democrats understand that we
really are looking at a blue wave this
coming November in the midterms
but that blue wave cannot happen if you
do not you know work on the
reunification of the Democratic Party
you know the establishment the
progressives you know the still with her
versus the Bernie bros all of that and I
don't use any of those as derogatory
terms you believe what you believe you
support who you support but all of those
people together have to push the
Democrats into office this November and
in order to do that the DNC has to show
that they are making positive steps to
be more inclusive to not let the elite
and the establishment have all the power
because you got to get the progressives
back in there now that isn't to say that
once they do that okay every Democrat
deserves your vote the Democrats will
have to earn it and they earn it by
coming up with a platform that addresses
the real issues that American citizens
care about student loan debt relief
predatory lenders the gap between the
haves and the have-nots Medicare for all
70% of support for that across the board
here those are the things they have to
talk about and when we have to get
sidetracked to fight over stupid things
like super-delegates who shouldn't have
any power to begin with that is time
that is taken away from issues that the
American public actually wants to hear
about I am I'm proud of the party and
the people who fought diligently to
strip super-delegates of some of their
powers that fights not over but right
now we're gonna hold that fight for
another day what's left right now is to
fight for a better party platform that
is a better reflection of what the
American public wants to see from their
politicians